ينضم لنا في الاستوديو ضيقوا على جائنا
الكوميدي والمثل اهلا بك صباحكم عربيه
ممثل مغني اااه كوميديان كيف تعرف حالك
للناس اللي ما بتعرفك
اللطيف
يعني اذا بقدر
بحب احاول نعمل
دراسه لانه الشهاده
معك يا رب طيب ضياء يعني هلا مثلا الاغاني
اللي عم تصدرها انت اليوم لو ما انت كنت
مشهور على السوشيال ميديا وكاميديا وبتعمل
ساده كوميدي ممكن كان الناس عندها فضول
تسمع اغانيه والا ربطوها فيك
كوميديا فلما الناس بتحبش الترهل او
التنوع والمشاهد خلاص
[موسيقى]
ما الناس اصلا بتحب العفاويه بكل شيء بس
بوم بوم اجت عفويه
والله على المسرح
[ضحك]
ههه
انت كنت كوميدي وناس تحبك وعندك متابعين
بالملايين على مواقع التواصل شو اكتشفته
اول احد العروض اللي عملتها ستاندر كوميدي
[ضحك]
احلى شيء فيها انه لما طلعت ما بعمل
كوميدي عملت ربع ساعه 10 دقائق ونزلت اعمل
المسرح والكلام الحفل في بئر زيت همم
15,000 شخص فانا ما بدي انزل يعني خلصت
اكثر من صوتك
بما انك عشت بامريكا مثلا انه تتجه لتغني
راب مثلا تكون رابر بالانجليزي وتخاطب
بالغرب مثلا
انبساط عرض حلو يعني لو بتحضر زي ما انت
شايفه ناس مبسوطه الرساله حتى وصلت لنفسها
لدرجه يعني الناس تسمعها مثلا انت بتسوق
بس اشي على المسرح اني انا اقضي 45 دقيقه
مثلا
همم
باين عليه 45 سنه
مين بربك على الراس
كله عفوي كمان عنوانك العفويه
وتقدم برامج ترفيهيه بين المقاطع مقاطع
السخريه وبين الغناء شو اتفضل انت شخصيتك
تحديدا
بضحك بحبك
بس للعرض للمسرح انا بدي اطلع على المسرح
بدي اقعد ساعه باحب اسمع المسرح كثير حلوه
بس اطلع على المسرح
الشاشه حلوه بس العرض لايف مباشر انت مش
شايف اللي بيحبوك قدامك الشاشه انت عارف
مين شايفك ومنه شايفك مين بحضركم بشيل مين
بيحضرك مكمل
الناس اللي بتحبك شو بدك تقدم لنا عرض
شكرا
انه يكون شامل اذا يقدر يكون باكدج وياخذ
من كل شوي ليش لا يعني الفكره بالناس
الناس الناس ما بتتقبل هذا الشيء يعني انا
كثير اتغلبت فكره ان الناس انه ضياع اللي
بيعمل عرض ضيع احنا بنحبك نضحك مرات بنروح
على العرض اللي بيكون متى فقرت الكوميدي
انا مش رايق مش محضر مش مجهز العروض اللي
نزلته هو دي جي وبتمشي عليه اغاني وراء
بعض كل عام وانت بخير شكرا جزيلا لك
حبايبي يعني شكرا شكرا